somebody may have fraudulently forged a
check in our name for a thousand dollars
sam's gonna go at the info right now
we're gonna find out we just looked in
our book the dates didn't line up they
said it was written on 324.
no checks written on 324 from digital i
have to call batman get him on the case
here
i'm actually impressed the bank said the
handwriting looked shaky today sam and i
are locking the edit for the movie that
means after tonight so we're gonna be up
late
after tonight no one else it's actually
april
mystery defense
that was yes
sorry no no no that no this is the
dollar amount this is the check number
how would you get the check numbers the
account numbers and the address
you did you have to once you threw away
like a bank statement i don't do that
though i shred them all
i find you and hunt you down
i'm gonna make you pay back every single
dollar
mcdonald's double cheeseburgers
yo carmichael you want a drone out dji
sent us a copy of the phantom 4 can do
like programmed actions really easily
and track you follow you so and so forth
they've taken away so many of the
technical aspects you need to worry
about it kind of makes having a drone
convenient finally there's a little
mount here where you can put an ipad or
a cell phone or whatever tablet
basically you use this as your screen
which is super crazy let's let's fly
what a ride so this is like is there
only one model like the pro man this
thing's so slick
my god
are you okay it's super windy yeah
oh it makes a fun little noise it makes
a new little noise
connect
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
remembers every song he's ever heard
he's like a living ipod
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey you wanna try almost crashing into
something
oh man
is it smart let's find out
oh it won't let it go forwards
it's smart are you give me that watch
watch you ready ready watch out dude
and
you're just you're just messing with me
no well let me go forward cool
i don't know don't yes yes that's a yes
it will hit it get it
nico please
maybe it will
turns out
two of our checks had been rewritten
name
date amount and a forged signature to a
fake person presumably but how did they
get it on our actual checks here's what
they did they used a process which
apparently is responsible for almost a
billion dollars in fraud every year in
the banking system a process called
check washing how these people got a
hold of our checks
we don't really know the only thing i
can assume is they broke into the
usps mailbox which is where i deposited
those checks
and then they closed it up and no one
was the wiser so unless someone at the
post office is doing this which isn't
completely unlikely but i wouldn't
presume it someone most likely just
broke into these boxes it's actually
pretty complex for how
much of a risk it is i mean what you're
talking about is if a person got caught
for this they'd go away for three to
five years in prison is it really worth
a thousand dollars
way to prevent this when you're at home
buy
gel based pens
if you can avoid it do direct payments
online
bring your checks directly to the place
of business that you're paying or
directly to the post office
i'm such a noob
wow i see it if i
at the right angle yeah
oh i see
probably pursue that and you guys will
finally get your tether movie